you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
renewable power capacity reaches record
levels across the world and is set to
grow even further
heartbreaking and deeply troubling the
verdict as a survey finds more than 90
percent of the great barrier reef has
been bleached
and extinction rebellion promises to
bring millions of people onto the
streets after the government says it
will crack down on protests
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world and hear
from the people being hit hardest by
those changes and reports on the race
for solution
well we start tonight with evidence that
many countries are moving to put
renewable power at the heart of their
energy strategies so latest figures show
growth in the capacity to provide wind
and solar power as energy security
becomes increasingly important
now record levels of new renewable power
were generated in 2021 and the world
added another 295
gigawatts of energy from solar and wind
and other sources to the supplies
available so one gigawatt is enough to
power a million homes and in 2022
the international energy agency
forecasts that new capacities from
renewables will rise to 320 gigawatts
that's the equivalent to the amount
needed by the whole of germany solar
power is used the most but wind is also
a large part of the current and
projected renewable capacity today both
norway and scotland made announcements
focusing on wind power in their energy
strategies norway will double its power
output by producing 30 gigawatts of
offshore capacity that's by 2040 while
scotland has announced a new partnership
with 24 organizations representing
nearly 32 gigawatts of current and
future wind power well correspondent
madeline ratcliffe is here now um so
this is quite encouraging and it comes
at a time when there's problems with the
supply chain and increasing costs yes it
is very encouraging we'll come back to
those supply chain problems and costs
because they are very relevant but it's
actually not good news for the reason
you might think it's not just because
there's been this huge push to get um
carbon emissions down around the world
and more more focus on those energy
policy policies although they've helped
it's actually it's sadly it's a side
effect largely from the war in ukraine
which has highlighted certainly in
europe just how much of our oil and gas
comes is imported from russia and now
there are huge efforts of course to
reduce that reliance but around the
world as well it's really shown a
spotlight on how secure how is your
energy supply even if it's from
countries which don't mind importing
from russia for now they don't want to
be caught in a position in the future
where
global events disrupt your energy supply
so energy security is key here and
really how do you make your energy
supply less vulnerable more secure you
produce it yourself and renewables are a
really important way of doing that you
don't need to have oil and gas reserves
to be sitting on them to generate more
power so a big part of it is this energy
security but the um the rising prices
come into it as well because actually
although the raw materials to make those
solar panels the the blades of the wind
turbines actually higher than they were
before the pandemic they've skyrocketed
and the cost of transport as a result of
all those supply chain problems we've
had so much about still going on they've
all pushed the cost of making these
solar panels for example up what's also
gone up at the same time is gas the gas
prices spiked as well and now it
actually becomes cheaper to use energy
to use energy from solar panels than
from gas potentially so that's the other
thing
playing a part here perfect while you're
here madeline let's take a look at our
data dashboard and i'd like your
thoughts on the situation in the uk for
the renewables here are they on target
well yes the government's ambitious
target is to have clean energy sources
100 clean energy and that's largely as a
result of renewables by 2035 and as you
can see quite a long way to go there and
that is the um the sting in the tail
really from of this report from the
international energy agency because
they've worn that great progress last
year record year this year again but
from next year that momentum starts to
slow the global policies climate
policies just aren't ambitious enough to
keep
driving those gains and we'll start to
see the sort of the growth plateau in
terms of what energy we get from
renewable sources okay madeleine thank
you very much
well let's take a look now at some of
the day's other climate news
extinction rebellion has announced plans
to bring millions of people onto the
streets after the government launched a
fresh bid to crack down on guerrilla
protests now the climate change protest
group has insisted the new curbs won't
stop people taking to the streets to
demand government action on climate
change the public order bill was
unveiled as part of the queen's speech
with harsher sentences and new criminal
offences for those involved in some
types of protests now relief
international has launched a carbon
credit scheme in which people can buy
credits to offshore their daily carbon
footprint credits are available at 15
per tonne of carbon generated by travel
food home energy choices and events and
money is then reinvested across africa
asia and the middle east now the global
agency's campaign aims to draw attention
to the disproportionate effects of
climate change upon communities in
fragile settings across the globe
shell plans to install 100 000 electric
vehicle charging points across britain
by 2030 the same year the uk plans to
ban the sale of new petrol and diesel
cars it all forms part of the energy
giant's plans to invest 25 billion
pounds in the country this decade
including 11 000 rapid machines now
shale currently has more than 5 000 on
street charges and around 140 rapid and
ultra rapid charge points on its
forecourts
alok sharma says climate change remains
a chronic threat despite a change to
international politics caused by
russia's invasion of ukraine now cop 26
president is leading an international
gathering of ministers in denmark with
egypt's foreign affairs minister who
will lead cop 27 in sharm el-sheikh more
than 40 countries will come together in
copenhagen this week to assess what
action is needed to deliver on key
commitments made at cop 26 talks in
glasgow last november
now more than 90 percent of great
barrier reef coral surveyed this year
was bleached in the fourth such mass
events in seven years now australian
government scientists say while
bleaching is caused by global warming
this is the reef's first bleaching event
during a la nina weather pattern usually
associated with cooler pacific ocean
temperatures simon bradshaw a researcher
at the climate council described the
findings as heartbreaking and deeply
troubling and called for more action
urgently
sadly the most severe bleaching is in
that central region that includes the
which sundays many of the tourist areas
now this information is of course
incredibly pertinent right now as we're
heading into an election it shows us yet
again that the very survival of the reef
is at stake and the science is clear
that its future depends on very
aggressive determined emissions cuts
this decade from australia and from the
world
well dr frank abadiblanco is a teaching
fellow in marine biology at the
university of portsmouth thank you so
much for joining us this evening um how
worried are you about this news
um
pretty worried and i think we all should
be this is a
very
um salient and and
obvious sign uh about how important it
is for us to halt emissions and to
reach the target of not getting to 1.5
degrees in order to save the world grief
and it's mostly because the greater real
reef is not only the largest in the
world but is one of the
best managed ones uh and the fact that
bleaching um
the greater regret of experience must
bleaching uh so frequently in the past
years is a sign of
how climate change is threatening reef
worldwide
what do you think this uh says about
climate change right now because uh
hitting that target of 1.5 of the world
warming up does this mean the complete
destruction of the great barrier reef or
is there hope that it could reverse
uh this this is a very difficult
question to answer basically because um
we rely on projections projections from
the data that we have and the latest um
research actually which was recently
published um
estimates that
at 1.5 only five percent of the reef
worldwide
could actually not surpass a
thermal threshold
within
10 years um
that means 95 of the reef as soon as
2035
will probably experience severe
bleaching probably annually or at least
every five years
and that's only at 1.5 degrees at two
the projections um are basically saying
that
probably the reef as we know them
uh will probably not um
be able to to keep us as they are
okay dr fran
thank you very much uh for your time
today
thank you
well do stay with us coming up
i'll be joined by climate justice
activist desergio and jess ralston from
the climate and energy intelligence unit
will be discussing that report on
renewable energy in a bit more depth and
climate process where's the balance to
be struck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm lisa dowd and i'm skye's midlands
correspondent we can reveal that the
driver who hit harry dunn is 42 year old
and sir cool ass just met the president
and we never thought we'd get this far
this is what they're up against is back
breaking work
water levels are dropping but no one
knows what impact further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary in this community i'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid
change seems tantalisingly close in this
corner of the uk
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news well let's get
a little bit deeper into some of those
climate issues that we've been talking
about with climate activists days agargy
and jess wolston from the climate and
energy intelligence unit um so first up
ladies thank you so much for joining us
um i want to kick off first with fossil
fuels fuels um because we must stop
using fossil fuels and
find other renewable ways to power our
world that's the clear and consistent
message from client science climate
scientists and the international energy
agency today reports some progress um
jess i want to start with you first
because i want to just
meander through some of the stumbling
points i guess um when it comes to the
supply chain we spoke about this earlier
in the show but how is the uk doing and
how realistic are those targets
first of all you know i think it's
really important to highlight that is
it's absolutely no surprise that the
world is increasingly looking towards
renewables
and that's for two reasons really so the
first reason is before the war even
started in ukraine fossil fuel prices
were rising
much higher than renewables like
offshore wind or solar power and so they
make more sense economically than fossil
fuels do but since the war obviously
there's been an energy security aspect
as well
and renewables you know they're
home-grown especially in britain we've
got such a strong offshore wind sector
and that this homegrown energy just
provides so much more security
on our supply than relying on imports of
oil and gas from places such as russia
um so it's very important but as you
said the uk does have some really
ambitious targets in this area so they
recently upped their ambition um on
offshore wind to 50 gigawatts by 2030 um
and just to put that in some context
that the eu has set a target of 60
gigawatts by 2030 for the whole of the
eu so you know the the uk is really
punching above its weight in terms of
targets for the offshore wind sector and
days i suppose the uk government are
becoming i suppose a world leader when
it comes to um offshore wind um you're
smiling there you're gonna disagree
tell us your thoughts
well i think the scientists have been
very clear with giving us a deadline
within this decade and i think that we
should start seeing our government
respecting those deadlines um so even
though it's ambitious in you know in
comparison to other countries
what's
what's good about being ambitious in
like a bad bunch you know
so yeah so that's what i think
i mean they have
in terms of sort of tech as well you
know the uk government have invested i
think it's 92 million pounds to sort of
push tech and green energy ideas so
they're doing their bit you have to
acknowledge there is some kind of effort
days
i think there is effort being made don't
get me wrong but at the same time
they're pushing tech development because
a lot of their mitigation has been based
on technology that doesn't yet exist um
so i i definitely do hope they're
pushing um for innovation in tech
because that's what they're banking on
and what if it doesn't work that's where
we start facing some real issues okay
dey's not not budging on that opinion
there jess i want to talk to you
i suppose about the rest of the world
when it comes to
renewables because we know that john
kerry has said this week hasn't he along
the lines of you know a long ukraine war
would threaten climate efforts um i mean
how much do you think on the flip side
have conflicts like this really pushed
the agenda of renewables for europe for
the uk for the rest of the world
yeah i really think that the ukraine war
has shown a spotlight on where we get
our energy from um not just the uk but
globally
and i think that you know lots of
countries are actually doubling down on
their renewables investments because of
what's happening
in ukraine
and in particular
the eu for example
has leaked a document yesterday
that suggested it would be further
upping its own targets
and other countries are doing the same
simply because renewables provide that
cheap source of energy
which is more secure than oil and gas
which comes from places like russia
and i expect that other countries will
also look to bolster their renewable
sectors um as things remain spiky and
volatile in fossil fuel markets um it
really is a hell of an incentive for
people to move away from oil and gas
when it's this volatile and this
expensive yeah it's a volatile market a
days but would you agree there with jess
that the the war in ukraine has then
made
governments you know look at where they
are and how they can do better
definitely and i think in this sad time
of where we see so much suffering we can
see the full effects of what may happen
if you know more fuel is put on the fire
in terms of climate change so i do
definitely think that in times of crisis
we've been using this to find really
strong roots out and roots out that can
be solutions for the future as well and
this is why i think going and looking
for pure forms and more green forms of
energy is just necessary
okay well i want to move on to another
subject now um extinction rebellion have
responded to the government's plan clamp
down on climate process by saying
they'll get millions of people onto the
streets um is there a risk of a backlash
from the public days
well i hope not i think i hope that the
public recognizes like what we are in
and the severity of this crisis
um i'm quite happy to see groups like
extinction rebellion basically saying
i'm not going to be bullied by my own
government and standing up and saying
enough's enough we need action on
climate change and i think all of us
should be part of that
there will be people days who will say
look i have been caught up in those
protests i've been trying to get to work
i have lost a job because i haven't been
able to get to that job interview
there's been incidents where ambulances
haven't been able to get through
and that's where public opinion i
suppose starts to change um what are
your thoughts on that
yeah i think to be honest like it's not
a fun thing to do and i think everyone
thinks we we get like giggles out of it
but that's just not the truth it's
really uncomfortable but then i also
recognize that like one uh we try our
best to mitigate against any
any issues around emergency services uh
the police does do know where we are
broadly because we tell them in advance
so there is logistical planning around
that but then also i think it's
recognizing like you know
there is something about putting
ourselves in the space of discomfort for
the future that comes and like even
though i understand it's very annoying
and i've even been stopped by extinction
rebellion protests but then i also
recognize what is the disruption that's
facing us if we don't address the
climate crisis and what's a disruption
that's already affecting many people
across the world people are dying from
this and we need to start taking it
seriously very quickly
jess some of the tactics used by
extinction rebellion gluing themselves
to lampposts blocking buildings um i'd
like to get your insight into whether
you think a public backlash is starting
to happen
i think the crucial point around this is
the british public fundamentally do want
to see climate action um it's actually
one of the top priorities for the public
at the moment despite you know the
coronavirus pandemic and what's
happening in russia and that's
highlighting again you know the need to
move away from fossil fuels so
fundamentally the public do back um
action and they actually want to see the
uk leading the way to net zero and
making the most of the opportunities
that net zero brings and i mean things
like jobs exports economic growth um all
in communities
that need it um but i think it's it's
you know it's really crucial that it's
the methods um which are divisive and
not the actual issue at hand um it's the
way they go about things rather than you
know people disagreeing with the cause
of the protest well days there's planned
legislation wasn't there in uh the
queen's speech earlier this week um but
said that mean harsher sentencing for
protesters um
you as a climate activist do you think
any of these measures will stop you from
going out and protesting
personally no because i know it's my
right within a democracy
i'm being an active citizen and i think
that's something to be very proud of and
i think all of us should come into
stepping up as active systems in our
democracy and not allowing a lot of the
stuff that is happening in our
government to continue you know where's
the accountability for all of the
ministerial codes that they've broken
where's the accountability for them not
achieving the targets they set
themselves that a lot of science don't
even think it's good enough anyway you
know and it's like if we have to get on
the streets to hold them account and to
go in the history of you know we aren't
the first
movement in the uk to use direct action
we are you know on the you know learning
from the lessons of people like the
suffragettes um so i definitely think if
we are going to start
seeing
legislation being used against us it
actually means we're probably closer to
the finish line than we originally
thought
and and jess briefly it would be
interesting to know how you feel about
this because you mentioned there is a
general public uh welcoming of climate
issues but when it comes to those uh
disruptive climate protesters do you
feel there's a different
viewing of what they're doing
i mean i think that's the question um
that opposed to today's on the british
government i think the crucial point is
that the public do fundamentally back
net zero and action to get there um and
it's a question for other people um
about how you know the public want to
put forward
their opinions on just how quickly we're
going um i do think you know some
climate scientists um have published
information in the last few months that
says uh the world as a whole is not
really doing enough um so i think people
can understand the motives behind
demonstrations um it's just a factor
of how they they go about doing it which
is um the question at play
okay jess days such a pleasure to talk
to you both thank you so much for
joining us on the daily climate show
well do stay with us coming up at nine
uh we're live from westminster it's the
take with sophie ridge who will be
joined by the leader of the democratic
unionist party sir jeffrey donaldson
thanks very much for watching we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]